Yeah.
In this video will introduce the different
type of neural network for natural
language processing, uh, known
as the recursive neural network.
So here we'll start,
uh,
interesting ourselves with the
problem of learning representations,
but not just for single words,
but also for multiple words,
same phrases or sentences. Specifically.
We like to be able to learn, uh,
representation, uh, of phrases
of essentially arbitrary length.
So for instance,
could we model the relationship
between individual words and multi word
expressions, which are
equivalent. For instance,
you could have a model that I learned a
representation for the word consider and
also can output a vector representation
of the phrase take into account,
which is similar to that a consider
because effectively to consider or to take
into account is essentially
the same thing. They're,
they're related essentially synonyms,
uh, with respect to each other.
So could we learn representation
with a model learning route,
presentation for arbitrary length,
uh,
phrases that allows us to compare full
sentences and that actually is able to
maintain as much information about it.
Semantic meanings. So fun. Since uh,
a model that would upload the vector
representation for the sentence,
word representations were
learned from our corpus,
that would be very close to an
equivalent sentence, which is a,
which as we train word
representations on a text dataset.
So that's the question we're going to be
interested in, in, in trying to address,
see how well we could learn he
fixed size representation of,
of these felony long sentences and still
maintain as much semantic information
as possible.
So to tackle this problem,
Richard Socher and his
colleagues introduced a
different type of neural network
today called eight
recursive neural networks.
So first describe the general idea
and the next videos we'll see it,
the look at the different
components and how they work.
So what they propose to do,
if we had a sentence,
say a small crowd quietly
enters the historic church, uh,
then to get a representation
of the full sentence,
they would first take the sentence and
extract from it a, a syntactic tree,
a binary syntactic tree,
which essentially identifies the internals
and tactic structure of the sentence.
So I'm not gonna say much about
what syntactic tree our tweets are.
Um,
but effectively essentially we have
data sets that identify four different
training sentences.
What is the syntactic tree?
And we were both to train models for,
for performing that.
And actually we'll be able
to use a recursive neural
network for performing that
task.
But essentially what the syntactic
tree gives you is that it identifies
essentially the meaningful,
uh,
phrases within the sentence
and how relate with each other.
So the syntactic tree here is saying
that there's a sentence which is composed
of in noun phrase and then the verb phrase
where the noun phrase covers a small
crowd.
So normally here there'd be a bigger tree,
but since we don't have enough space,
you should imagine that there, there,
there would be a small tree here and,
and so that forms a noun phrase.
And then we have a verb phrase,
which essentially covers
all of these words here.
And this verb phrase is actually a smaller
verb phrase covering quietly enters
and a followed by a noun phrase.
Just probably the object
of quietly enters and a,
this non phrase covers the historic
church and this non phrase,
it's actually a determinant
followed by a smaller noun phrase.
And this smaller numb phrase is an
objective followed by her now specifically
historic following church.
So that's the kind of information that
is contained in these barn recent tactic
treats.
And now to get a representation in vector
representation of the full sentence,
a d idea and recursive neural net
is to recursively merge pairs of
representations of smaller segments to
get representation is not cover bigger
segments.
Specifically we'd start with the word
representations themselves and then going
up in the tree,
we will take the two parents of a
note and merged our representations,
uh,
using a neural net,
which will take as argument the two
representations and now put a new merged
representation so far.
For instance,
the first thing you could do is take
the word representation of the word
historic and then the vector
representation of the word church.
Feed that to our neural network,
which would then output a new vector,
which would be the,
uh,
which we use as the representation
for the noun phrase historic church.
And then to get the
representation at that level here,
vector representation that we'd merged
the representation of its to children.
That is the word, the, and then the
noun phrase for which we just extracted,
computed. It's a merge representation.
So now we'd feed to the same neural net,
this vector and this factor,
and then it would output the vector
representation at that level.
And we continue like this for each node
in the syntactic tree until we reached
the route. And that vector would be, uh,
considered in our model as the vector
representation of the full sentence.
So what we need to specify at this point
is what shape will take this model that
merges pairs of representations. And, uh,
also all we going to model
actually the tree structure.
And specifically how are we
going to extract this? Uh,
this street's a structure
from the sentences.
And these are the things we're going
to discuss in the following videos.